AND THE STOCK MARKET HAS NOT HAD
MUCH OF AN APPETITE FOR TARIFFS
LATELY.
>> Bill: WE WATCH THAT.
THANK YOU, JOHN ROBERTS, FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE.
MEANWHILE, AN ADULT MOVIE STAR
IS MAKING MORE ALLEGATIONS
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT TONIGHT.
WHILE SOME CONSIDER THIS A
GROWING STORM THAT IS GOING
NOWHERE, OTHERS CONTEND IT IS A
COVER UP IN THE MAKING.
CORRESPONDENT KEVIN CORKE SORTS
THROUGH THOSE CLAIMS TONIGHT.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS DENIED THE
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST HIM, AND
AGAIN, THIS CASE HAS ALREADY
BEEN WON IN ARBITRATION.
ANYTHING BEYOND THAT, I WOULD
REFER YOU TO OUTSIDE COUNSEL.
>> WHILE THE WHITE HOUSE
CONTINUES TO SUGGEST THAT THE
STORMY DANIELS STORY IS PURE
FICTION, THE LEGAL RAMIFICATIONS
OF THE ONGOING CONTROVERSY ARE
ALL TOO REAL.
DANIELS, WHOSE REAL NAME IS
STEPHANIE CLIFFORD, CLAIMS IN A
LAWSUIT THAT HER NONDISCLOSURE
AGREEMENT, PROMISING NOT TO
DISCUSS OR LARGE PAST
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE PRESIDENT
WHEN HE WAS A PRIVATE CITIZEN,
IS NOW INVALID.
>> WE BELIEVE THE NDA WILL BE
TOSSED OUT.
WE BELIEVE IT WILL SHOW THAT
MR. TRUMP NEVER SIGNED EITHER
DOCUMENT AND THEREFORE, SHE'S
FREE TO TELL HER STORY.
>> MR. TRUMP HAS DENIED EVER
HAVING HAD A RELATIONSHIP WITH
DANIELS.
MANY LEGAL EXPERTS BELIEVE THE
AGREEMENT IS VALID.
THE CONTRACT WAS SIGNED BY THE
PRESIDENT'S PRIVATE ATTORNEY
MICHAEL COHEN, BY DANIELS, BY
HER ATTORNEY, NOTARIZED, AND
DANIELS TOOK THE MONEY.
$130,000 THAT COHAN SAYS HE
PAID.
AS A NEW TACTIC.
EARLIER, THE DANIELS TEAM
CLAIMED THAT HE VIOLATED THE
NDA.
NOW THEY SAY THE MISSING
SIGNATURE OF DAVID DENISON,
A.K.A. THE PRESIDENT, IS THE
ISSUE.
STILL, CONGRESSIONAL DEMOCRATS
KATHLEEN RICE OF NEW YORK AND
TED LIEU OF CALIFORNIA, BOTH
FORMER PROSECUTORS, HAS
ABOUT THE FBI TO INVESTIGATE THE
PAYMENT, WHICH THEY BELIEVE TO
BE IN VIOLATION OF FEDERAL
ELECTION LAW, A POSITION SHARED
BY THE LIBERAL LEANING WATCHDOG
GROUP COMMON CAUSE, WHICH HAS
FILED COMPLAINTS WITH THE FEC IN
THE DOJ.
>> WHAT WE REALLY HAVE IS A
WOMAN WHO REALLY WANTS TO TELL A
STORY AND A LEGAL AGREEMENT
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT SHE CAN.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, ASIDE
FROM THE ACTUAL LEGAL ISSUES,
TRUMPS LEGAL TEAM NEEDS TO
DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT IT'S WORTH
THE FIGHT.
>> THE ARBITRATION VICTORY THAT
SARAH SANDERS WAS APPARENTLY
REFERRING TO WAS A TEMPORARY
RESTRAINING ORDER THAT THE
PRESIDENT'S PRIVATE ATTORNEY WAS
ABLE TO GET FROM AN ARBITRATOR
SOMETIME LAST MONTH.
BY DANIELS 'S ATTORNEY SAY THAT
THAT ULTIMATELY CAN PROVE
UNENFORCEABLE BECAUSE AS
THEY CONTEND, THE PRESIDENT
NEVER SIGNED THE NONDISCLOSURE